so this is a story that is notable but
it's notable for different reasons than
most of the people who are reacting to
it think it's notable for one of donald
trump's election fraud lawyers jenna
ellis quit the republican party
live on her television program yesterday
she hosts a show called the truth on
real america's voice i don't know what
that is either but that's what it is
that's what it's called and on that show
yesterday she said she's out she's out
of the republican party until further
notice but why is she out because as far
as she's concerned the republican party
isn't crazy enough the republican party
isn't fighting hard enough
to argue
that donald trump actually won the 2020
election and so she's leaving now i'll
explain more in a second but let's first
look at the clip
all of them including ronna mcdaniel
should resign now
until they do as of today i am resigning
from the party i am changing my voter
registration and i am no longer a
republican until the party decides that
it wants to be conservative again even
if i stand alone for the truth i will
stand for the truth a compromised
corrupted majority is not a majority
worth being a part of if we genuinely
want to create a more perfect union we
have to stand up for our principles
against the corrupted machine of
self-serving politicians in washington
so what is this all about
jenna ellis is quitting because some
emails leaked where a top republican
national committee lawyer
criticizes what jenna ellis was doing
vis-a-vis election fraud with rudy
giuliani and the whole lot of them in
the november election and in the months
following it and jenna doesn't like it
jen is personally insulted
there actually were some people in the
republican party who are still
republicans and i don't agree with them
on policy but there were some
republicans in the republican party that
realized after the 2020 election that
joe biden won donald trump lost that's
it and that when jenna ellis and rudy
giuliani and sydney powell
were going around the country holding
these hearings flying around the country
passing covet among themselves remember
jenna got it rudy got it etc
rudy got it etc claiming these
conspiracies about there were massive
dumps in the middle of the night and
there was a van with food and all of
this stuff there were some republicans
including people like ronna mcdaniel and
others in the republican party who said
we look ridiculous we're becoming a you
know we're becoming an even bigger
laughingstock they would say it's just
we're not looking good they were already
a laughingstock stock it was becoming a
bigger one and jenna ellis is mad that
not everybody was on board with her
election conspiracy theories and so
she's quitting the republican party in
protest this isn't a principle than
moral republicans saying the party has
abandoned me i will no longer vote for
republicans i am going to the democratic
party or i'm moving to the left that
that's not what this is
it's someone saying
the party isn't nutty enough i'm too
nutty essentially for the republican
party and so i'm leaving and here she is
in a painfully long-winded clip
explaining more about why she's doing
this so jenna
why would you want to stay
in the republican party you uh doesn't
sound like you uh have a home there and
i heard i was just passed a note that
you might have an announcement uh to
make regarding your affiliation as a
republican
yes well i also announced today that i
am leaving the republican party until
the republican party comes back home to
conservatives i will stand up and
champion truth conservative principles
our declaration of independence as
america's charter and the u.s
constitution but i will not stand and
abide by a party that says that we have
to support everything that comes under
the banner of our even though it's not
conservative for rana for example to
tweet um in affirmation of pride month
for this whole infrastructure bill for
what mitch mcconnell said about
president trump in the aftermath of the
second impeachment hoax all of these
things are not conserving our principles
of liberty and justice for all they're
not conserving our constitution so i'm
not going to stand by and support a
party that doesn't support my values and
if every single registered republican
who's a true conservative demands of the
republican party okay so at some point i
have to just cut it i mean this went on
for several more minutes not not a
concise explanation but
all that stuff about the constitution
and all of what she's saying what she
means is not everyone at the republican
party is on board with my embarrassing
and flaccid attempts to steal the
election and i'm mad that they thought
what i was doing didn't make any sense
so the bigger story here is
is this going to develop into a bigger
schism or rift in the republican party
which could damage them in 2022 which i
would love
it's too early to tell
remember that jenna ellis is in the
pro-trump side of the party people like
ronna mcdaniel
i guess they're sort of like trump
agnostic i think mcdaniel realizes if
the party's voters are with trump the
leadership probably needs to stick with
trump too but she seems to realize trump
is sort of a cartoon so unless it's
really clear that the voters are
abandoning trump i don't think this
fracture in the party is going to become
serious and as you know if you've been
watching the show for the last few weeks
republican voters are overwhelmingly
with donald trump right now now what
would be interesting
this is sort of a smaller question than
will the party completely crack into
what what's an interesting question to
consider is whether there will be a real
fight
as to whether the 2022 campaigns of
these republicans up for reelection will
be run on
2020 was stolen by democrats and joe
biden that's one way they could run in
2022.
they could run on policy
right
or they could run on
you know democrats are communists and
joe biden's a marxist and that's really
really bad my instinct is that trump and
the national media figures are going to
keep pushing the election was stolen and
that's why we need to win 2022 narrative
but i think republicans at the local
level at least many of them are going to
go with not policy no they're not going
to go with policies done for this party
local republicans or at least
republicans that have to focus on how
they talk about the election in their
district with their constituents are
going to go with communism and is bad
and democrats you know gas prices and
marxism and spend spent spend that type
of thing they've totally abandoned
policy
and that would be
an interesting thing to see in 2022 do
they run on the election was stolen or
do they run on we've got to stop this
communism which of course doesn't exist
i think it will be the latter
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you fifty percent off because you are in
my audience you just answer a few
questions steadymd will match you with a
licensed primary care physician that's
tailored to your needs you'll have a
one-hour virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
no risk no long-term commitment the link
is right underneath the video